[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily a florida
physician
mother of two bludgeons a death this
is a brutal murder investigators track
key suspects across the country one with
the nickname matching the murder weapon
jimmy the hammer but this isn't case
closed yet
text messages from the suspects traced
back to the victim's husband
he said that he'd hoped that we'd have
some time to to be able to talk
privately was this a murder for hire a
loveless marriage turned deadly
or a caring father wrongfully accused
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we're taking an inside look at the trial
of a florida man accused of killing his
wife
and business partner mark severs is
charged with being the ringleader
behind the murder of dr teresa sivers a
colleague found the doctor beaten to
death in her own home
the murder weapon a hammer mark sievers
the husband is one of three men accused
in the case
curtis wright pled guilty a jury
convicted jimmy rogers of the lesser
charge of second-degree murder
the state opened their case describing a
phone call mark seavers made to write
his best friend his best friend was
telling him he was desperate
his best friend was pulling at his
heartstrings saying that he would lose
the girls
and that his girls steve's girls would
be in danger
and wayne wright said he would see what
he could do
during those conversations mark sivers
made clear there was a lot of insurance
money
and he would pay wayne wright over a
hundred thousand or more
to murder teresa sivers and mark severs
knew
of wayne wright's precarious finances
on may 17th after jimmy rogers agreed to
help the serious planning began
mark sivers picked the time
a time when he and the girls would be
out of town the perfect alibi
siva's defense tried to cut down the
state's motive saying the sieber's
marriage wasn't a happy one
and they called star witness curtis
wright a liar
he'll tell you that he lied on several
occasions
but was never administered a polygraph
to determine what if any of his
statements
were truthful to any degree
of scientific certainty mark was
primarily
responsible for raising their two girls
josephine and carmela or
josie and carmy as they like to be
called
girls for good homeschooled students who
are busy with extracurriculars
the state will present evidence
that mark and teresa were on the cusp of
bankruptcy
except for the fifty thousand dollars in
cash that was lying around the house
and the vacations and the donations to
charity and their comfortable lifestyle
so how did investigators link the murder
to the defendants
law and crime daily's angenette levy
reports on the investigation
yeah brian well detectives tracked
evidence from the crime
from florida to missouri and enlisted
the help of the fbi's crime lab
now surveillance video from a walmart in
naples shows wright and rogers the
morning the murder was committed
just a few hours after the murder the
two are seen in a gas station headed
north on their route home
microscopic fibers found on dr seaver's
leg
the kitchen floor and rental car driven
by wright and rogers
match the coveralls found thrown away on
a rural road in missouri
coveralls located with the help of
roger's girlfriend
who told authorities about a startling
admission from jimmy rogers himself
i knew that you had something to do with
this and then
did you ask him a question i did
what did you ask him i asked him
noted for the record overruled i had
asked him if he killed her with a gun
and what did he say to you no
did he tell you how he killed her he
said
they killed her with a hammer
now the lee county sheriff's office
actually agreed to pay shoemaker 400
as the case awaited trial the defense
went after that on cross-examination
i don't know how to explain it i don't
remember them asking to agree
to do it i just remember going forward
and telling them that i wanted
to help with it
okay further you agreed to testify
against mr sivers correct
yeah at that time you had no job is that
correct
no i didn't you had no money coming in
is that correct
i mean jimmy worked we had his money
coming in but
and after that you continued to
co-reside with mr rogers is that correct
um no not really what do you mean not
really
i started staying with my mom
now shoemaker says she actually turned
rogers into police because she was
fearful for her life
and the lives of her children brian
thank you man jeanette now terry austin
is here with me to break down the case
terry what did you make of this
so-called bedside confession
you know brian i think shoemaker's
confession was
extremely credible she was afraid of
rogers when she realized
what he was capable of doing she wanted
to protect herself
she wanted to protect her children and i
think that's why she went to
to the police actually and the 400 i
don't think that makes her
you know not believable i think it's
just something for whatever reason
they wanted to pay her for doing her
testimony
so you didn't really think that the
defense's cross-examination asking if
this was kind of like
money for for her testimony that didn't
really take you anywhere
in terms of uh how this case played out
it didn't brian he had to ask that
question he had to make it seem
as though she was getting paid for her
testimony but i think she was still
credible all right i tend to agree as
well
still ahead on law and crime daily a
best friend testifies in this so-called
murder for hire plot
should we believe this jailhouse niche
is this plea deal too good to be true
or are there three killers really to be
blamed stay with us
back now to the trial of a husband
accused of killing his wife
and the testimony of the state's star
witness prosecutors say curtis wright
was a longtime friend to defendant mark
sivers seavers traveled to missouri for
wright's wedding
in may of 2015 and allegedly asked his
friend for a big favor
in exchange for a hundred thousand
dollars in insurance money
wright confessed to driving to florida
when he knew dr seavers would be home
alone
to commit the murder in the gallery the
doctor's mother
and sister struggled to control their
emotions
i panicked i jumped up and i followed
her into the house
i hit her the hammer where i where i hit
her at was
she she was turning to the right not
necessarily the back of the head but
kind of the side i actually think that
she thought i was mark
um she said why right after that third
the third time i swung jimmy came from
my right side
and just started started
blasting her over and over and over i
think she actually had one hand on the
countertop
but he just kept hitting her and then
she ended up going down
onto the floor and after she was on the
floor face down he continued to hit her
when he kept hitting her on the floor i
asked him a couple of times
you know i said jimmy stop you know is
it enough
and uh he wouldn't stop so i uh
i actually went over there and put my
hand on his shoulder and
just like you know like stop
on cross the defense press right about
what he initially said to the police
about the relationship issues between
the defendant and the victim
you told them you're telling me that
they had marital problems
i was close and i've never heard that
he never talked to me about that do you
recall saying that to detective levitt
yes you said that
teresa was having an affair do you
recall that
do you recall saying that i recall
saying that's what mark told me
mark was concerned that she uh she would
take the kids if she left you recall
saying that
yes where is she gonna go i don't know
he said out of state but specifically i
don't know
okay for the next three to five minutes
levitt asked you about your sexual
preference didn't he yes
sustained detective levitt wanted to
know if you had a
sexual relationship with mark sivers
didn't you
objection relevance sustained
prosecutors went back to wright with
text messages between him and the
defendant
around the time of the murder
hope you're having a nice day that's on
the 27th the day before you killed dr
sivers you were on the way to florida
isn't that correct
yes and your phone was in missouri and
then there's
no other message to or from
mr sievers between 627 when you're on
your way down here with mr rogers to
kill dr sivers
and june 30th right right and then on
june 30th
you text him and he said i just talked
to scott being scott cephus right
yes you're telling him in the message
that you're
basically sorry yes that message was
cover
wasn't it yes there were i mean there
was real feelings there but
yes i mean obviously you already knew
what happened scott sivers didn't have
to tell you that theresa sivaris was
dead
did he no you knew he was dead
she she was dead um in fact you knew
that
somebody might at some point see these
messages right
yes attorney terry austin is back with
me
terry i know as attorneys we often
forget
what's behind us and focus on the
cross-examination of the witness
but you saw the family visibly upset
during the description of the murder
what was your reaction when you saw how
that family reacted
you know it's always very difficult for
the victim's family to listen to the
gruesome details and you know from the
testimony of
right here that there was you know pain
and suffering
she knew what was happening she asked
why are you doing this
so it's very hard to see the mother
there very upset but it's something i
think
helps with the entire situation to at
least
know in the last minutes of the victim's
life
what was going on as gruesome and
difficult as it might be
now terry wright had a lot to gain with
his testimony was he believable to you
i do think he was believable brian and
even though
he is you know quote unquote a felon
he's an admitted liar his testimony was
corroborated by the evidence for
instance
he said that they used burner phones and
the evidence showed that they did
in fact use burner phones so if it had
just been his testimony that's one thing
but it was corroborated
all right corroborated testimony from
that of what many are calling the
jailhouse niche
coming up on law and crime daily will
the jury believe that mark sivers was a
loving husband
or a conspiring killer the jury's
verdict after the break
[Music]
we're following the trial of a florida
man accused of orchestrating his wife's
murder
as we wrap up one final question for the
defendant
have you had enough time to talk to your
lawyer about whether or not you should
testify
yes do you need any more time
what would you like to do today sir
a display of confidence the defense
argued that their client is innocent in
the death of dr sivers
and place the blame squarely on curtis
wright
the only evidence you have of someone
promising payment came
from curtis wayne wright and then when
we asked mr wright
his answer was i don't remember mr
wright is not allowed
to forget failure of memory
is an insufficient reason to allow
mr wright to retain his advantageous
plea deal
prosecutors say mark husband mark sivers
was the one who put the whole plan
into motion and that the conversations
between he and curtis wright
proved it but
for mark sievers theresa seavers
would not have been found dead on her
kitchen floor
in a pool of blood
but for mark sivers a brutal
homicide would not have occurred
but for mark sivers
mark seavers is the catalyst
mark seavers is the cause
mark sievers is responsible for teresa
sivers
brutal murder and he should be
held so accountable
the jury was sent out to deliberate
after about four hours
they reached their verdict verdict
we the jury find as follows as to the
defendant in this case
count one first degree murder the
defendant is guilty
of first degree murder conspiracy
the defendant is guilty of conspiracy
so say we all december 4th 2019 by the
four person
so that's the verdict terry were you
surprised to hear that word
guilty i was not surprised because i
thought the prosecution was able to
prove the case
beyond a reasonable doubt there was so
much
evidence against seavers they had the
witnesses they had the physical evidence
but you know you never know because
sievers wasn't there
and so they may have thought that he
didn't actually do the murder
now terry this is a it's kind of a weird
question but do you think this loss is
on the defense attorney
or was sievers just guilty from the
beginning
well you know i think the prosecution
did a better job he's a great prosecutor
but i think the defense did as well as
he could have
under the circumstances there was so
much evidence against sievers i don't
think anyone
could have won it on behalf of the
defense
but there were certain things that i
think the defense didn't do well i
didn't like the fact that he said the
prosecution didn't prove motive of
course he proved motive there was a
financial gain
so there were some things he didn't
argue well but at the end of the day
there was too much evidence against his
client yeah i
tend to agree as well especially when
you have uh
someone who's a part of that that kind
of idea of murdering your wife
testifying against you pretty hard to
overcome that
thanks terry when we come back one final
question for the jury
will it be life in prison or the death
penalty for mark sivers
find out next
[Music]
now to the death penalty phase and then
trial of convicted murderer mark sivers
a florida jury found severs guilty of
killing his wife dr teresa sivers
by promising two other men money in
return for the killing
one of the two men testified for the
state that he helped
kill dr sivers with a hammer the other
was convicted
by a separate jury prosecutors are
asking this jury to put to death
the husband convicted of orchestrating
the crime the victim's mother
testified
my teresa was murdered in the most
brutal
unimaginable way it was the weekend that
teresa's 8 and 11 year old daughters
would become motherless the weekend
our family would lose a life force that
we
her friends and patients and anyone
fortunate enough to meet her
relied upon her to lift us up
teach us how to heal ourselves and
challenge us to be
the best people we could be my daughter
theresa was an extraordinary woman
a powerful force determined determined
to change the world
she had enormous compassion for all
people
especially the neglected and the
abandoned
and that passion could be seen in the
way she lived her life
i used to call her my modern day mother
teresa
i always knew she would grow up to do
great things
and she did the defense called mark
zebra's mother to talk about what the
defendant is like as a father
he was very hands-on he was the
stay-at-home dad
he also worked at the
teresa's office managed that and so
forth
but as the father he would
get involved in all the girls activities
he always taught them how
and so did theresa about virtues and
what's right and what's wrong
and to talk about feelings and he was
really
very good at that and very loving
have you visited him since he's been
incarcerated
every week sometimes twice a week
and then every monday so you love your
son
very much he's very caring very
kind very thoughtful always wanting to
make sure you're okay and if your son
was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole would
you continue to support him
of course he's he's my baby
he's my son and i would always be there
for him
the jury went out to deliberate one
final time and returned in just under
three hours
aggravating factors as to count one we
the jury
unanimously find the state has
established beyond a reasonable doubt
the existence of
the capital murder was committed for
pecuniary gain
no we the jury unanimously find that the
state has established beyond a
reasonable doubt the existence of
the capital felony was a homicide and
was committed in a cold
calculated and premeditated manner
without any pretense of moral
or legal justification yes we the jury
unanimously find that mark sivers should
be sentenced to death
yes all right so terry there you heard
what the jury came up and it comes to
the penalty phase
agree or disagree i totally agree the
jury recommended the death penalty
judge kyle said yes absolutely the death
penalty
you know sievers tried to say that he
was innocent even though the jury
found him guilty i think the judge
didn't like that and if you remember
judge
kyle said i judge people's actions
not their souls and if he's wrong may
god have mercy so i think this was the
right decision
yeah and i kind of was interested in how
the jury broke it down
with those aggravating factors they
seemed to check off a lot of those boxes
did those boxes make sense to you when
they went through them and checked them
off they did
absolutely and you know what this tells
us brian the jury took this
seriously they made sure that those
aggravating circumstances
contributed to the penalty of death they
did not just say okay he was involved
let's
you know sentence him to death they made
sure that it was
such a heinous crime based on financial
gain
and they said this individual we have
the death penalty
he is one of those people who deserves
to use it
yeah of course we're not just talking
about an individual who
murders their wife in the heat of
passion this seems to be
if all the facts are correct and the
jury decided they are
a man who pulled in two other men to
kill his own wife
i would tend to agree with you here at
terry the jury i think got it right
based on the decision terry thank you
for joining us and thank you for joining
us here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you